ryan gosling and Ava Mendez party with  Beyonce and jay-z now you're making me  nervous the 36 year old actor and his  ladylove stepped out together in NYC  after Ryan hosted the season premiere of  Saturday Night Live and jay-z performed  I love it  Ava and Ryan looked happy in casual  attire the 43 year old actress stunned  in this 70s inspired romper and black  chunky heels as Ryan rocked a sweater  vest jean jacket and blue pants for the  outing queen v also attended the  after-party in support of her man the  singer looked casual chic wearing a  white long sleeve top high waist navy  blue pants and tan chunky heels while  hubby jay-z donned a quilted red velvet  jacket a black tee and matching jeans  the power couples were seen entering  town nightclub for the SNL after-party  [Music]